a massive solar field when finished it
will cover 141 hectares roughly the size
of 265 football fields break it down and
you get this tons of aluminum framing
nearly 200,000 specially designed mirror
panels and over 72 kilometers of heat
gathering tubes these are the building
blocks of a simple yet powerful
technology it's called concentrated
solar power or CSP say solar power and
most of us think of roof panels
photovoltaic or PV technology these
glass encased solar cells convert
sunlight directly into electricity
problem is these solar panels capture
just a fraction of the sun's energy and
they're too expensive for large-scale
use concentrated solar power on the
other hand doesn't create electricity
directly instead it captures and
concentrates the Rays of the Sun to
create heat much the same way we did as
children but in place of the small
magnifying glass Nevada solar one uses
huge parabolic or curved mirrors when
the Sun heat that the mirrors is
reflected just here this is what a
parabola does every every point under on
the mirror got to one line this line is
like a magnifying glass getting really
really hot the mirrors it's made of very
very clean glass
there is no iron in it so it's it's if
you compare this glass with your window
the amount of flies that can get in in
is hundred times more than a window so
it goes to the silver surface and it's
reflected that's where they are so so
efficient
these mirrors focus the sun's rays more
than 70 times their normal intensity
onto a single focal point a long
cylinder filled with synthetic oil
called a receiver tube the liquid
travels through rows of mirrors and
gathers more and more heat until it
reaches temperatures of nearly 400
degrees Celsius the hot tube then passes
through a heat exchanger where water is
turned into steam
finally like in traditional power plant
the steam drives the turbine to produce
electricity